bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport numéro 31 c'est parti pour 26
minutes de reportage d'image de match et
d'interviews sur la cus port de tout le
département nous reviendrons sur le
derby de basket en nationale 3 entre
trappe et l'entente le
chesnay-versailles ce week-end pour le
compte de la 3e journée match qui a vu
la victoire de l'étoile des cheminots
trappe également dans ce set 8 sport
zoom sur les féminines de l'entente
voisin saint-arnoult c'est du tennis de
table après plusieurs montées
successives elles débutent leur seconde
saison en nationale 2 avec un statut
tout nouveau de favorite et dans cette
émission nous nous arrêterons avec mes
invités sur la cinquième édition de
l'ekiden ce marathon par équipe de plus
en plus populaire se déroulera ce
dimanche à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines et évidemment en fin
d'émission comme d'habitude tous les
résultats du week-end mais tout d'abord
place aux baskets et aux débris fin du
derby entre trappe et l'entente tauch
universel
je le disais il y avait ce derby ce
fameux derby tant attendu entre trappe
et l'entente le chesnay-versailles ce
week-end du côté du gymnase paul mallet
attrape et rappela emporté 80 69 et
romain dubosc l'entraîneur de l'entente
au chesnay versailles nous fait l'amitié
d'être parmi nous ce soir bonsoir à vous
alors un petit moment avant de faire
leur entrée un petit peu plus
précisément dans ce débrief déçu ou
satisfait quand même un peu du
comportement de vos joueurs sur c'est
sur ce match
comportement qu'on a pu avoir sur le
terrain on est déçu parce que l'on ne
peut pas satisfaire d'une défaite c'est
sûr mais dans l'ensemble on est
satisfaits ce qu'on a pu faire et on
sent qu'on n'est pas passé très loin
alors je le disais c'était le premier
derby en fait d'une longue série 1 pour
pour cette poule de nationale 3 cette
saison en recevant l'entente le
chesnay-versailles l'étoile des
cheminots de trappes avait l'occasion
d'affirmer sa suprématie sur le
département et ses ambitions pour la
montée en fin de saison de son côté le
fcv romain pouvait enchaîner par une
troisième victoire consécutive
récit de ce match avec patrick jacques
de dixmude et olivier maniscalco
comme un signe pour son premier derby
trapy sur le banc versailles et romain
du beau ça prouve son ancien formateur
mostafa el hafidi c'est un match
particulier ça fait dix ans je crois
qu'on n'a pas vus interdits traversa et
donc forcément ça a une saveur
particulière moi j'étais j'étais gamin
quand j'ai vu dernier match de trappes
versailles donc c'est un peu particulier
même pour moi on va démarrer ce match là
plein pot comme on sait le faire
on va jouer notre chance jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout ils tenteront de
contrecarrer la marche en avant
saint-quentinoise notre équipe est
meilleure de semaine en semaine c'est
une équipe tout jeune en âge mais
également en cohésion puisqu'ils se
connaissent depuis un mois 1 est donc
cette cohésion est en train de se
construire largement dominé dans les
airs les versaillais m comme prévu
beaucoup de riz ou dès les premières
minutes de jeu pour surprendre la
défense saint-quentinoise et avec 15
fautes d'équipé au cours de la première
période l'un discipline trappistes coûte
cher après avoir eu six points de retard
les versailles et bascule logiquement en
tête à la pause 35 33 passes au jeu très
offensif des visiteurs les trappistes
répondent par une belle adresse
extérieure et un festival de dunks de
diallo mameri en fin de match les jeunes
joueurs saint quentinois prouve leur
maîtrise devant l'expérience
versaillaise les trappistes pour la
loire rebond est toujours aussi adroit
au shoot il creuse l'écart pour
finalement s'imposer 80-69 la marche
était un peu haut pour le lcd face à une
équipe taillée pour la nationale 2 on
sait que c'est un derby il fallait
assurer
qu on en fait ce qu'il fallait on a
appliqué les consignes du coach et puis
ça a payé
et donc je le disais avec avec roland
dubeaux c1 l'entraîneur de l'entente au
chesnay versailles vous le disiez vous
n'avez pas été très loin vous étiez
proche quand même vous avez fait ce que
j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait sur ce match
mettra péter était au dessus on sait
qu'ils descendent de nationale 2 oui oui
c'est une équipe très physique c'est
très compliqué de jouer contre eux c'est
un jeu très haché avec beaucoup de
lecture beaucoup de rigueur dans le
système offensif qui qui nous fatiguent
beaucoup parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'écrans donc on est toujours obligé de
prendre deux trois écrans avant de jouer
un contre un où défendre sur un contre
un an plus tôt donc ça a été compliqué
on s'en est pas rendu compte tout de
suite à la mi temps on était de 22
points mais dès que
la fatigue s'est ressenti on a 100 a vu
qu'on était la débauche d'énergie en
première mi-temps s'est vu en fin de
compte sur les deux gardiens on a vu
qu'on était moins du site sur la fin et
là où on est censé avoir de l'expérience
on n'a pas réussi à la cité notre basket
et c'est tout à leur honneur d'ailleurs
eu de leur côté d'avoir réussi par
contre le à maintenir le rythme jusqu'à
la fin que faut-il travailler encore sur
les prochains matches pour vous essayer
justement de gbagbo hisser à ce niveau
là j'ai fait un choix cette année deux
de jouer à un jeu en lecture assez riche
une motion donc on le sait que c'est
difficile c'est long à apprendre je
savais que les premiers matches de
championnat on serait pas encore prêt
donc j'ai hâte de voir un match retour
par exemple où on aura fini de se
préparer
malheureusement je sais que tu rappes
fonctionne de la même manière on l'a vu
dans l'entourage du staff à l'un de mes
premiers formateurs donc je sais aussi
comment il travaille je sais que à la
fin du championnat son équipe sera
encore plus dur et pourtant sur le
papier on va dire vous partiez un petit
peu favori si on regarde les classements
avant le malade classement puisque vous
étiez vous étiez devant les trappistes
ouais tout à fait maintenant bon le faux
pas de trappe à gennevilliers faudrait
revoir le match n'ait pas vu je pense
qu'il ya quelques soucis même là bas
donc d'après ce que j'ai pu entendre je
pense pas qu'ils vont lâcher beaucoup de
matches dans la saison je pense que
c'est une équipe qui va finir sur le
podium et vu la qualité du travail on va
les attendre tout en haut c'est sûr là
on vient de voir le classement actuel un
précèdent cette troisième journée vous
êtes évidemment un petit peu redescendue
et attraper deuxième vous vous dans le
bon wagon encore on est deuxièmes
ex-aequo voilà ce qu'on attendait encore
beaucoup d'équipés dans un dans un petit
mouchoir de poche et j'ai remarqué aussi
que certains anciens trappistes sont
venues du côté des bleus et verts tout à
fait faux direct mais logica qui a joué
et qui a fait les belles années de
trappes 1 à l'époque c'est quelqu'un
avec qui j'ai commencé le basket donc
pour info il a commencé à versailles
d'abord et si avec moi qu'il a commencé
et ensuite il a rejoint trappe donc
yarouba diakhaby aussi et tu en fis ci
qui est aussi de notre club mais cas pas
pu jouer ce match là malheureusement
pour d'autres raisons mais oui c'est
vrai que j'ai d'anciens trappistes et
que ça avait une saveur particulière on
aurait bien aimé gagner ce match station
place il arrivait un peu tôt ce dernier
vous le disiez il arrive un peu tôt et
en même temps comme je vous le dis je
pense que c'est aussi une équipe qui va
être plus forte d'ici quelques mois donc
on avait notre champ je pense samedi
soir et voilà il fallait faire un match
encore plus parfait que celui qu'on a
fait pour espérer l'emporter quel va
être votre objectif cette saison c'est
que la n3 c'est un niveau vous
connaissez quand même à l'entente le
chesnay versailles on va essayer de
grappiller quelques places la montée
c'est trop compliqué la montée c'est
trop compliqué et puis on n'est pas là
pour faire de l'ombre au beau parcours
des filles on veut que l'on veut
qu'elles fassent leur parcours en l1
nous derrière c'est le challenge sportif
on a recruté des joueurs qui sont
d'abord passionnée par le basket
donc on n'a pas les ambitions de la
montée maintenant sportivement on
essaiera d'atteindre la plus haute place
quoi qu'il arrive donc on vise un podium
même si on sait qu' il ya de grosses
réserves ça va être très dur même et
cette poule elle est particulière un
autre titre vous lisiez ainsi un niveau
très relevé il ya un niveau très relevé
dans cette poule mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de clubs l'illinois puisque il
y attrape évidemment cette vous et il y
à poissy il ya plein qui est pour
l'instant leader de cette poule qui vise
aussi la montée tout à fait qui à mon
avis va être une équipe quand on n'a pas
entendu beaucoup parler encore mais mais
qui est très solide et qui pour info
aussi à l'entraînement deuxième
formateur en tant qu'entraîneur celui
que j'ai eu le plus longtemps et qui
vous n'êtes pas ses mots en fin de
compte pour alger parce qu'il traitait
une belle surprise de voir que les deux
personnes qui m'ont lancé dans le basket
et qui m'ont fait aimer ce sport sont
actuellement des adversaires en tant que
coach donc alexandre mekdoud da poissy
m'a coaché pendant cinq six ans à
versailles donc c'est clair que j'ai eu
beaucoup de choses aussi et je sais que
son équipe va malheureusement pour nous
très bien joué au basket a longtemps
mentionné versa évidemment vous le savez
on parle beaucoup des féminines en
nationale une qui ont réussi l'exploit
de monter la saison dernière est ce que
c'est difficile de vivre un petit peu
bas dans l'ombre de des filles stéphane
rolland
c'est pas difficile parce que on est à
là on est à l'origine de ce projet j'en
fait même partie on a proposé ça il ya
quelques années quand j'étais joueur
dans l'équipe première de versailles
quand on s'est rendu compte que on était
montée en n2 et on n'a pas su assumer
financièrement le budget pour se
maintenir ça a été très difficile de
monter trois années en quatre ans pour
redescendre l'année suivante d'entrée
j'ai donc fais partie de ceux qui ont
proposé à ce qu'on fasse les choses un
peu mieux que faire monter les filles
semblent être la meilleure idée parce
qu'elle était mieux armé que nous à ce
moment là
et que je pense que financièrement on en
était capable au club alors que les
garçons ça demandait beaucoup de choses
il fallait qu'on reparte sur des bases
celles de la formation et qu'on permette
aux filles d'abord d'accéder au haut
niveau pour capturer et puisse nous
tirait aussi vers le haut une fois
qu'elle y seront installés vous
retrouver la victoire la semaine
prochaine en championnat on espère même
si le client est aussi gros contrat
puisqu'il affiche également les
ambitions de montée ils ont recruté pour
ça vous jouez contre qui le ministère
des finances donc ça va est également un
très gros match invite tout le monde à
venir voir le match à 20 heures
dernière question romain qui est un
petit peu parallèle au basket est ce que
lors de la préparation physique il ya
beaucoup de footing beaucoup de courses
pour les pour les joueurs de l'entente
le chesnay-versailles y en a pas mal oui
maintenant cette année on a choisi quand
même de très vite attaqué le jeu mais on
a l'habitude de beaucoup courir en faire
un travail spécifique quasiment d'entrée
et on fait ça surtout tout au long de
l'année on va passer peut-être à une
compétition qui vous intéressera
peut-être indirectement c'est l'ekiden
la cinquième édition on passe tout de
suite au débat
je le disais cinquième édition de
l'ekiden un ce marathon par équipe
inquiète de plus en plus populaire avec
déjà plus de 50 équipes inscrites
francis ponge bonsoir à vous comme
d'habitude évidemment vous êtes
l'organisateur de l'ekiden et que cela
expliquait nous un petit peu mal au
concept de la course tout simplement moi
le concept c'est de couvrir la distance
du marathon 42 km 195 en équipe ça se
dispute sur le circuit de 5 km et il y a
6 relire ça c'est les compétitions
officielles de la ffa ou il y aller cher
demeurant la faire assaut française à
clé nous nous avons près la formule de
l'ekiden loisirs détente essentiellement
donc on a fait un parcours de 2 km 5 me
couper la poire en deux mais nous
conservons les relais classique 5 km 10
km 5 km et 10 km 5 et 7 km 195 et on
peut aller jusqu'à combien de relayeur
alors sur une épreuve comme celle-là
loeb l'épreuve officielle de d'ekiden c6
relier obligatoires maintenant ça
commence un petit peu à venir nous
depuis cinq ans on a pris l'option de
prendre de quatre à six coureurs pour
les plus gourmands peut-être un petit
peu qui voilà quelques-uns qui sont un
peu costaud qui veut le faire des
séances d'entraînement
fractionnez un petit peu dur donc ils
viennent k4 donc ça fait doubler les
rues sur des relais donc ça fait une
bonne entraînement quand même ouais
c'est une préparation justement pour les
sert à rien oui pour les marathoniens
c'est une bonne préparation faire 1 5 ou
1 10 bornes bien de travailler
sur des terrains en pleine nature ou et
c'est agréable et en revanche c'est
qu'il donne est ce que c'est un bon
format si on manque un petit peu de
condition qu'on dépassera les 10 km par
exemple après c'est un petit peu
plusieurs c'est le format idéal c'est le
fonds mondial surtout sur le type de
courses que nous on organise où
n'importe qui peut venir nous on a
essentiellement des équipes
d'entreprises des équipes de quartier
qui viennent qui se montre on a des
parents qui viennent avec leurs enfants
qui au 17 18 ans donc voilà c'est une
façon d'approcher la course à pied
différemment faire 5 km certains qui
arrivent à le faire en footing donc
c'est pas un problème et ça permet de
côtoyer l'ambiance des courses ça permet
également de se frotter un petit peu au
club parce qu on a quand même quelques
clubs de référence comme les îles comme
montrouge ben epidote qui viennent donc
voilà sept ans mais tout le monde de se
frotter un petit peu il ya une distance
minimum pour un équipier dans une équipe
à parcourir sur l'étude à nous c'est
aléatoire non c'est pas aléatoire il ya
il faut fixer des relais dès le départ
donc un rôle hier le premier fixe 5 km
le deuxième lui à l'oeuf et 10 le
troisième fait 5 le quatrième fille 10
le cinquième fait sec et le 6e fait 7 km
195 il ya une tactique idéale pour pour
empocher la victoire à la fin peut-être
mettre le plus costaud sur la longue
distance il y à des tactiques web ça
dépend des des clubs si on est un tueur
un format de quatre coureurs ou de 6 il
y en a quelques-uns qui ont déjà mis des
tactiques au point je pense à nos
collègues de laizy
qui tourne bien qu'ils ont choisi les
options de prendre les
les gros coureurs pour le fond de la
piste sur le 10000 par exemple et de les
mettre sur la distance de 10 km parce
que l'assassin voie dure comment dire
combien des petites distances on peut
voir des athlètes de la piste venir
peut-être c'est ce billet un peu sur les
quidams vous il ya quelques heures qui
viennent des clubs des alentours qui
veulent s'essayer qui va nous faire un
petit 5 km d'entraînement
j'avais vu notamment les coureurs de les
îles acquis préparer les championnats de
france justement de semi marathon bon il
ya quelques saisons qui sont venus avec
open de la piste c'était impressionnant
fallait voir un peu con ça déboule et
sur 5 km
mais il ya des équipes étrangères je
crois cette année un sommeil alors ça la
nouveauté cette année c'est un petit peu
un nouveau t on travaille beaucoup avec
la ville de trappes avec la communauté
d'agglomération de la base de loisirs et
la vie le trapy jumelée avec une ville
tchèque est donc dans le cadre
d'échangés sportifs il ya deux équipes
tchèques et qui vont venir participer à
l'ekiden co-prévenus tx1 pour la pour
l'album et j'ai réussi à le dire
correctement
il ya un mode d'inscription ci change un
petit peu cette année est ce qu on peut
encore s'inscrire ou pas alors cette
année on a vraiment essayé d'évoluer au
travail en douceur on prend le temps de
faire les choses comme il faut les
inscriptions se font uniquement par
internet les gens s'inscrivent il ya un
site sur le le site du club respecté
point com et là ils inscrivent leurs
coureurs y téléchargeurs certificats
médicaux tout se fait sur internet mais
ils peuvent le faire jusqu'à jeudi soir
le long du site rappeler le mot juste
pour
tous les spectateurs il ya le situer
donc du club c est valide points à
disputer point com et là ils vont sur la
rubrique course à ekiden ou course à
pied et trouveront toutes les
informations rendez vous donc ce
dimanche 13 octobre à 9 heures à 9
heures à la paresse à la fraîche ça je
crois que c'est garanti pour dimanche je
ne garantis pas le soleil c'est un lieu
très bien merci beaucoup francis d'être
passés sur le 7-8 sport et merci aussi à
romain et puis et bonne continuation
pour la fin de la saison
après deux montées successives sans
transition place au tennis de table les
féminines de l'entente voix 500 tarn où
s'affirme plutôt bien en nationale 2
pour leur seconde saison au haut niveau
dernière preuve en date leur écrasante
victoire à roubaix ce week end 8 0 elles
ont désormais l'étiquette de favorite 1
pour la nationale une nous avons vu le
voir comment elles vivent ce nouveau
statut
il est fini le temps où les joueuses de
l'entente voisin saint-arnoult était un
peu comme le cadeau surprise au pied du
sapin le soir de noël on ne sait pas ce
qu'il contient mais la réponse est
souvent éclatante et pour leur seconde
année en nationale 2 levy sinoise
doivent assumer leur nouveau statut est
ce compliqué à gérer parce qu'on est
l'équipe à battre donc on sait très bien
que toutes les équipes vont renforcer
sort nous avons essayé de jouer leur
match sur nous c'est qu'ils ont inventé
alors que l'année dernière j'avais moins
peur de nous puisque on était la petite
équipe une petite équipe qui a bien
grandi malgré un premier match gagné
dans la douleur face à saint denis les
saint-quentinoises montrent déjà leurs
progrès au niveau il fallait cette
victoire pour lancer la peau je pense
que maintenant les filles à son passé il
faut se rappeler aussi que l'année
dernière on avait commencé la poule avec
une défaite à la dernière sur poitiers
en n2 pareil même match match très
compliqué les filles pas dedans on perd
et en fin de compte derrière on arrive
devant poitiers ont loupé la montée au
début quand à l'intersaison seule la
jeune sarah bonaly est venu renforcer
l'équipe levy sinoise en ont profité
pour partir en stage à marjo vol dans le
languedoc ça permet déjà de reprendre
l'entraînement et en plus de coûter
alors ça c'est pour nous c'est aussi
valable pour les plus jeunes s'attendre
à ce qu'il y ait un groupe de porter
sans s'en aller
les parents sur les si un petit problème
et c'est sûrement grâce à cette cohésion
que camille ponsin concentrer sur son
parcours scolaire a resigné un voisin
cette étude c'est un peu compliqué parce
que je les études en plus et donc pas
j'ai un moment en tête le pipeau
mais pour le coup
les yvelinoises ne cachent pas leur
ambition derrière leurs raquettes en
phase une ou en face d'eux la montée en
nationale une reste l'objectif
prioritaire
place tout d'abord au football une fois
n'est pas coutume 5e journée de division
d'honneur versailles est bien le roi du
match nul les joueurs de david giguère
ont ramené d'issy les moulineaux un beau
0-0 des familles c'est leur cinquième
match nul en autant de journées cette
saison ils sont douzièmes au classement
mais meilleure défense avec deux buts
encaissés en promotion d'honneur vous le
voyez cela s'affiche poule b 3e journée
trap est allé s'imposer à courbevoie 2-0
et se hisse à la deuxième place avec 10
points à deux longueurs de nanterre dans
la poule c nouvelle défaite pour lui en
course cette fois ci à domicile face à
sainte-geneviève 3 2 les le sg pointe
désormais à la 10ème place et n'a
toujours pas gagné cette saison en foot
féminin chez les femmes les équipes
saint-quentinoise n'ont pas existé 1 ce
week-end en promotion d'honneur tout
d'abord samedi au stade guy-boniface
c'était portes ouvertes les amazones
d'elancourt ont perdu sur un score de
babyfoot 9 0 on ne va pas vous montrer
tous les buts car cela prendrait un
petit peu trop de temps mais juste un
condensé un des réalisations parisiennes
qui ont eu à faire une défense
saint-quentinoise aux abois avec cette
défaite des joueuses de dane elec son
huitième de leur poule de promotion
d'honneur on voit un des derniers buts
en foot féminin toujours division de
cette fois-ci montigny a pris à peu près
le même tarif en fait un face à algrange
ce dimanche pour le compte de la 4e
journée cette fois ci les joueuses de
jordanie grossesse sont fait étriller 7
0 et sont lanterne rouge de leur groupe
avec ce déjà 19 buts encaissés moyenne à
peu près de 2,5 buts par match
place au rugby plaisir à réaliser le
carton de cette quatrième journée de
fédérale 3 à boulogne billancourt face à
la cbb avec cinq essais et le bonus
offensif en prime le prc s'est imposé 40
16 les joueurs de philippe berre
confortent leur deuxième place avec 14
points à 5 longueurs du leader orléans
place au basket on a vu l'entente le
chesnay-versailles chez les hommes chez
les femmes cela marche bien aussi
troisième journée de national une
l'entente enchaîne avec une seconde
victoire face à ifs 64 assouan à 53 les
filles de stéphane drolet remonte ainsi
à la cinquième place de leur poule de n1
handball toujours chez les femmes
montigny espérer se changer les idées il
faut le dire avec le deuxième tour de la
coupe de france face à cergy-pontoise ce
week-end cergy un pensionnaire de
division 2 et bien c'est raté lésigny
monteyne toujours sans leur entraîneur
stéphane paysans se sont logiquement
inclinés il faut le dire 30 à 20 tout
autre sport le bmx vous le savez à
voisins il y à un club qui marche bien
c'est le voisin bmx loeb et ben il
accueillait la 7e manche du championnat
d'île de france ce week-end dans les
finales de l'après midi le v6 noir et me
mention a remporté la course élite et
vous le voyez à l'écran un peu plus tôt
un autre vie sinois swan thierry arts
avait raflé la mise plutôt facilement
chez les cadets à noter la belle
performance d'ensemble un des pilotes de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui ont été au
total 12 à monter sur la boîte à l'issue
du week end
placé au tennis de table on en parlait
de l'entente voisin saint-arnoult chez
les filles dans la nationale 2 dans une
autre poule il ya il encourt est il
encore est allé chercher le match nul à
oullins rillieux ce week-end sept
partout pour le compte de la 2e journée
les élans courtoise restent bloqués
comme elle à la 6e place au classement
général autre événement autre sport
c'est la course à pied à la place de
l'ekiden là c'est le parcourir montini
la 19ème édition seraient déroulés ce
dimanche aux alentours du complexe
pierre de coubertin au terme des 10km de
course c'est grégory cheval qui s'est
imposée en 31 minutes et 52 secondes
soit une moyenne d'à peu près 20
km/heure un juste en dessous il récidive
après avoir remporté en avril la 33e
course du printemps et pour sa première
participation aux 10 au 10 km 1 de
parcourir montini il était plutôt
content de son temps elle écoute on est
parti relativement prudemment on est
passé au premier kilomètre en un peu
moins de 20 à leur pardon on est resté à
troyes jusqu'au deuxième kilomètre et
donc à 2 jusqu'au 3 4e kilomètre et
après j'ai fini tout seul et j'ai essayé
de maintenir un rythme pour passer en
dessous de 32 minutes en volleyball s
montini a enfin débloqué son compteur
victoire lors de la troisième journée de
régionale une les il y monte à se
déplacer à clamart et se sont imposés 3
sets à 1 avec un dernier set de folie un
gagné 34 à 32 de son côté plaisir
toujours leader s'est défait facilement
de vincennes en trois petites manches
montigné de son côté reste 6e pour leur
hockey en suis évidemment le début de
saison en nationale 2 dès shox
d'elancourt deuxième journée est il
encore se déplacer à vierzon cette fois
ci et les prédateurs n'ont pas fait de
détail victorieux 13,2 des chocs ce avec
2 deux défaites en autant de journées
l'apprentissage de la n2 est pour
l'instant très difficile pour le chox
une dernière info résultat vous nous
vous le faisions découvrir la semaine
dernière dans le circuit de sport je
veux bien sûr parler de yann dujarrier
le nouveau champion d'europe du surprise
du kilomètre catégorie master est bien
quand nous l'avions rencontré un le
belize et un se préparer également
championnats de france marathon de
roller cette fois ci qui se sont
déroulés ce week-end à valence d'agen
dans le tarn-et-garonne mais
malheureusement pour l'illinois ça a
moins souri il a échoué au pied du
podium après une course perturbée par
les orages et un changement de roue
enfin comme vous avez maintenant
l'habitude l'agenda du week-end pour les
prochaines compétitions à d'accoucher
sur votre calendrier évidemment la
cinquième édition de l'ekiden départ 9
heures ce dimanche dimanche 13 octobre
c'est ce marathon par équipe je le
rappelle sur la sur la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines côté roller
hockey premier match à domicile des
chocs ce d'elancourt face à rouen ce
samedi à 20 heures au gymnase chastagner
pour le compte de la troisième journée
de nationale 2 et enfin vous le savez
cette semaine c'est la semaine du
handicap du côté de
montigny-le-bretonneux et il y à une
démonstration de hand fauteuil que vous
pourrez voir ce samedi matin à 10 heures
30 au complexe pierre de coubertin fait
une démonstration faite évidemment par
les sélections des yvelines ce 7,8 sport
touche à sa fin merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à nous
donner tous vos résultats les résultats
de vos clubs et commenter cette émission
sur les réseaux sociaux via twitter avec
le hashtag le 7-8 sport tout attaché à
lundi prochain bonne soirée